okay for this video we're going to look
at the second qubit a chi fairly gloomy
Shuang is a few interesting bits and
pieces to it has been a few changes over
the years I'll be doing it she'll talk
about where things have changed they're
not necessarily you know right there
they were right in there there now
wrongman yeah they're just different so
hmm there's you learn different aspects
from doing in different ways
okay so keeps all fairly open wide some
of the changes that we've made
okay in the first video I see some of
these are snapshots so don't necessarily
start you know necessary starting in
this position though obviously you are
but the exercise and this is this was
quite a good demonstration because the
attack yuki does doesn't he's not very
practical from this sort of position was
he be David makes things easy he's
attacking the leg so he's gotta be here
now I could reach you very easily
without before he gets into range
so yes have some significant time on me
to make me react to block that otherwise
I can just sort of counter it very
easily now there's no hint emitting
there as we both raise up the defender
is following the attacker and that sort
of raises last but it's not quite enough
to create that time gap
I mean that boy will attack but yeah
this is this is the exercise so we check
from here we show from the attack and
this is quite interesting creeps in the
first so folks praise he starts he
raises up he takes the leg
now that's very simple finish I could do
from there yeah he can't really reach me
so with it but I shoot he's managed to
time I didn't have to respond to the
attack so look at it from this point of
view a snapshot he's actually got more
time I blocked down here now from here
now because of this geometry how this
works
he's risked his in within range of my
sword
so I raise a zither to cut put your
wrist hallelujah
okay so that's the line of his wrist I'm
down here that's the attack button doing
these risk okay so from here I raised to
attack as this comes up he raises the
point of his sword the other side now I
can no longer get to attack you I have
to change my mind I hold this on line he
comes around for a thrust and I blow
back and parry and that's the first part
cue catchy now this part up the left now
or it kinda gets lost where you go fast
but I always avoid looking to get that
attack okay so it gives this gives us
off change your fingering I think he's
quiet are you doing these otherwise you
just saw going backwards now things
happen I say things have changed I like
the sort of the changing feeding that
gives me rather than just yielding to
his movement opening immunity that's
kind of like a personal thing you may
see it differently but that's fine here
so preciously this one is I can leave it
open or my clothes now used to be more
emphasis on keeping his light to him
close which case it's gone it's not
worked really hard to hide around my
sole wish I think he's good
now what he doesn't open these hip
breathe he'll outwards and that ship's
line he's lying slightly and then get
around my soul okay so this next part
loogie boys around you I do I Drive the
soul my blades back now comes with
strike
yeah now again this is Denise doing this
now turn that over and opens the line
for him to straight in other way is to
click back back to what I try to do is
come in for a little struts if it drops
up the lead change the mind and we're
back into this position now it doesn't
really matter which one you do it's long
johnstad which one you're doing and why
are you doing it okay so one I told over
open the line he comes he drops on the
straight in
that's me my team in the other way is
also do this more on the move you can
kind of start this deflection higher up
as the source coming down well time to
create a locally so I can attack II ever
change my mind they all either one is
fine white doing entirely up to what
your teacher does you do okay so show
the whole thing
[Music]
first variation to come up this Cup as
he comes in for the thrust I moved to
the side shoulders wrists okay
the first body variation uses a similar
move they come up further cup raises I
move into each type position I'm
controlling his body with the point of
my sword except the khopesh thumb down
the back middle finger of the song I
turn over here like a it's difficult the
throws he's got structure is too strong
so I use blade to
[Music]
second variation as he comes for the cup
my answer stripe basically a ribbon
naked or a group and a ruby the second
pointy variation I basically did the
same entry blue said look at the safety
technologies down okay so the second
qubit variations while interesting quite
interesting cubit actually also things
in there to work okay thanks for
watching
[Music]
you